y
tuvo vivió unas inéditas manifestaciones
que no se veían desde 1994 miles de
personas marcharon en la habana y otras
ciudades del país en rechazo a la grave
crisis económica y sanitaria hubo
reportes de heridos por disparos de la
policía tras el llamado del presidente
miguel díaz canel a enfrentar a los
manifestantes
el presidente de francia emmanuel macrón
se dirige a la nación este lunes y se
espera que anuncien nuevas medidas
destinadas a contener una cuarta ola de
contagios en el país de cara a la
reapertura del verano los casos de
contagio continúan en aumento debido a
la presencia de la variante delta del
corona virus se especula la vacunación
obligatoria para el personal de salud
italia consiguió su segunda eurocopa
tras vencer a inglaterra en la final del
campeonato en una agónica definición
desde el punto penal mientras el país
celebraba en inglaterra las tristeza
estuvo acompañada de expresiones de
racismo contra los tres jugadores que
erraron sus penaltis
el primer ministro boris johnson y el
príncipe william rechazaron estos hechos
feliz de inicio de semana y bienvenidos
a una nueva emisión de noticias en
france 24 los saluda andrés meza muñoz
iniciamos en cuba donde miles de
personas marcharon en varias partes del
país en contra del gobierno comunista o
las manifestaciones inéditas que no se
veían desde 1994 con el conocido
maleconazo durante la jornada se
produjeron violentos enfrentamientos
entre la policía y partidarios del
gobierno contra los manifestantes
pacíficos la protesta surge en un
momento de crisis en la isla que sufre
una fuerte escasez de productos básicos
y el recrudecimiento de la emergencia
sanitaria por la pandemia
al grito de libertad hacia abajo la
dictadura miles de cubanos salieron a
las calles de varias ciudades del país
en una de las mayores manifestaciones en
contra del gobierno cubano rechazo a su
gestión de la pandemia de kobe 19 la
escasez de alimentos medicinas o los
apagones de luz diarios como vivo por la
represión que hay con el pueblo que no
tienen matando no de hambre
ya estamos en casa las protestas
estallaron de forma pacífica en el
municipio de san antonio de los baños
pero se replicaron tanto en la capital
la habana como en el exterior con el
apoyo de la comunidad cubana en el
exilio la policía cubana intentó repeler
las manifestaciones por la fuerza con
violentos choques entre los
manifestantes y los pro gobierno que
dejaron varios heridos pueblo salió al
presal se libremente y están reprimiendo
respuesta a la inédita ola de
manifestaciones en su contra el líder
del partido comunista existo a sus
partidarios a tomarse las calles listos
para el combate militarizando las calles
de la capital donde se produjeron
también apagones de internet y telefonía
móvil o vamos a admitir que ningún
contrarrevolucionario
mercenario
bendigo al gobierno de los eeuu vendidos
al imperio recibiendo dinero de las
agencias vayan a provocar
desestabilización en nuestro pueblo y
habrá una respuesta revolucionaria y por
eso también aquí estamos convocando a
todos los revolucionarios del país
a todos los comunistas a que salgan a
las calles en cualquiera de los lugares
donde se van a producir estas
provocaciones el inédito estallido
social en cuba llega en un momento de
fuerte crisis social y económica en la
isla agravada en parte por las sanciones
de eeuu y la emergencia sanitaria
pasamos a haití la policía de este país
anunció la detención de uno de los
presuntos autores e intelectuales del
asesinato del presidente joven el mois
el pasado miércoles las autoridades
identificaron al individuo como
christian emmanuel shannon quien reside
en florida y habría volado al país
caribeño en junio acompañado de guardias
de seguridad contratados según dicen con
el objetivo de asumir la presidencia a
este resto se suman a este arresto se
suma al de 18 colombianos y dos
haitianos estadounidenses
este año el salón christian emmanuel
shannon quien se encuentra bajo control
policial litera votar
estuvo en contacto con una empresa
venezolana especializada en seguridad
ubicada en los eeuu base estación
la policía ha bloqueado los avances de
estos bandidos quienes luego de haber
cometido el crimen a uno de ellos
contactó a christian emmanuel shannon y
también se pusieron en contacto con
otras dos personas que reconocimos como
los autores intelectuales del asesinato
del presidente unión y lemoiz juju nasa
bill y la alta comisionada de la onu
para los derechos humanos michelle
bachelet presentó un informe sobre el
racismo sistémico y las violaciones de
derechos humanos del que son víctimas
los africanos y los afrodescendientes en
el mundo el reporte presentado en la
sesión 47 del consejo de derechos
humanos de la onu en ginebra hace
especial referencia a la muerte de georg
floyd en eeuu
la oficina recibió información sobre al
menos 190 muertes de africanos y
afrodescendientes a manos de
funcionarios encargados de hacer cumplir
la ley el 98% de las cuales tuvo lugar
en europa américa latina y américa del
norte
en ciudad su vez además de examinando de
cerca siete incidentes emblemáticos de
muerte de africanos y afrodescendientes
en contacto con agentes del orden
incluidos george floyd y brión a taylor
en eeuu
adama traoré a dama traulen francia
lohan a barbosa del rey santos y joao
pedro matos pintó en brasil a tu
espíritu en brasil
kevin clark en reino unido- y jeanette
garcía palomino en colombia en general a
pesar de los diferentes sistemas legales
ciertas prácticas patrones y desafíos
parecían similares incluida la
recurrencia de prejuicios raciales
estereotipos y perfiles types profiling
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
anunciara este lunes medidas para
prevenir una cuarta ola de coronavirus
como muchos en europa francia está
experimentando un aumento de contagios
debido a la variante delta veamos entre
visitas a la playa el suroeste de
francia
estos parisinos optan por unas
vacaciones con actividades inusuales
nosotros vamos al centro de vacunación
en hungría los franceses ahora pueden
recibir la primera y segunda dosis de la
vacuna en cualquier parte del país
hay menos restricciones para las
personas respecto a la reserva de citas
para venir a diferentes centros nosotros
podemos tener la primera inyección en un
centro y la segunda en otro alrededor de
40 por ciento de los franceses están
completamente vacunados y el gobierno
espera que más sigan el ejemplo al igual
que el número de contagios aumentan las
preocupaciones sobre una cuarta ola la
semana pasada los casos nuevos
aumentaron en un 60% en comparación con
el promedio de la semana anterior y el
lunes se registraron más de 4000
contagios mientras tanto el número de
personas hospitalizadas con el virus se
estabilizó durante los últimos dos días
luego de haber disminuido durante varias
semanas en un intento de mantener las
cifras bajas el presidente de una norma
con anunciará medidas el lunes un
movimiento probable según un funcionario
del gobierno es la vacunación
obligatoria para los trabajadores de la
salud el consejo científico dice que las
tasas de inoculación para el grupo son
demasiado bajas especialmente en los
hogares de ancianos donde sólo la mitad
de los empleados
las vacunas algunos políticos están
pidiendo que se amplíe el uso del pase
de salud lo que significa un requisito
de vacunas o pruebas negativas para
restaurantes teatros y otros lugares en
lugar de solo clubes nocturnos y grandes
eventos
italia venció a inglaterra 3 a 2 en la
tanda de penales el sábado en la final
de la eurocopa 2020 la escuadra azurra
regresó triunfante a roma donde los
jugadores fueron recibidos por cientos
de fanáticos mientras tanto en
inglaterra la tristeza y la decepción se
sumaron desafortunadas expresiones de
racismo contra los tres jugadores que
erraron sus penaltis todos de
ascendencia afro desde la monarquía y el
gobierno han condenado estos hechos los
detalles con nuestra corresponsal en
londres louis ha pulido
en medio de esta mezcla de emociones
tras la derrota de la eurocopa 2020
especialmente de tristeza y frustración
inglaterra amaneció masivamente
rechazando los abusos racistas online
contra los tres jóvenes futbolistas
basterds saca y sancho que ayer cerraron
los tres tiros penaltis frente a italia
el primer ministro en su cuenta de
'twitter' dijo que deben ser tratados
como héroes mientras que el príncipe
william que es el presidente de la
asociación inglesa de fútbol dijo que
esta situación debe detenerse
rápidamente y los responsables deben
responder la policía está investigando
esta situación y esta mañana a través de
un vocero de twitter ha dicho que se han
removido más de 1000 tweets y se han
suspendido permanentemente un número de
cuentas pero la presión aumenta sobre el
primer ministro para que obligue a las
compañías de redes sociales a adoptar
medidas realmente importantes que frenen
este tipo de comportamiento de las
personas a través de redes sociales pero
la jornada de la final de la eurocopa
fue también un caos y anarquía para
londres 49 personas
son capturadas 19 policías heridos y al
menos 100 personas ingresaron sin tener
tickets ni pruebas negativas de kobe al
estadio de wembley donde se estaba
jugando la final quienes asistieron han
denunciado que no había suficiente
presencia policial para lo que requiere
un evento de estos de talla mundial
hasta aquí este avance informativo en
france 24 quédense con nosotros
[Música]